if you forgive the poor attempted Irish
tamasha Walia I'm at home
President Biden clearly takes pride in
his Irish heritage
as long as I can remember it's been it's
been a part of my soul he enjoys
dropping old Irish sayings into
conversation if you're lucky enough to
be Irish well
you're lucky enough and when presented
with a Mongolian horse named the animal
Celtic
now Biden has visited his ancestral home
for the first time as president in what
was both an important personal
pilgrimage and a demonstration of
American soft power abroad
the second Catholic president's visit to
Ireland came 60 years after the first
John F Kennedy I want to say that I'm
happy to be here tonight I continued a
long tradition of U.S leaders gracing
the Emerald Isle I want you to know that
for this great grandson of Ireland this
is a moment of Joy any American
presidents have described there are days
either visiting Belfast or Dublin as
some of the best days of their
presidency Bill Clinton visited three
times George W bush visited twice Barack
Obama visited once and now Biden who
claims a lot of Irish ancestry during
his trip Biden visited the place his
mother's family came from met the Irish
president and addressed parliament in
Dublin the United States was shaped by
Ireland and that's not hyperbole the
influence of Biden's Irish Roots has
long been seen in his political rhetoric
his speeches for example often make
references to Irish poetry you know as
the great Irish poet's Sheamus Sandy
monstro history says
don't hope on this side of the grave but
then once in a lifetime the long four
tidal wave of Justice Rises up in Hope
and history rhyme
it's everything I've been taught I think
for President Biden the experience of
being Irish and the historical
experience of of Irish living under
British rule is a way that he uses to
sort of connect with oppressed
minorities in other parts of the world
so he's made a real part of his his
political worldview my background
in the background of my family is Irish
America
and uh
we have a
long history
of
not fundamentally unlike the Palestinian
people with Great Britain and their
attitude toward Irish Catholics
over the years Biden's Irish connection
has helped strengthen already strong
links between the U.S and Ireland I
think it's fair to say that today we're
celebrating our national day with a
president who is unmistakably a son of
Ireland
being a son of Ireland has also got him
out of one or two verbal gaps in the
past a lot about it is mom lived in Long
Island for 10 years or so a God Rest her
soul and uh
um although she's wait your mom's still
your mom's still alive is your dad
passed God bless her soul
there's an old Irish proverb as some of
you know that I heard my grandfather use
but never really applied to me before he
said it goes a silent mouth is sweet to
hear
well I'm going to yield to that proverb
I think the Irish in general are very
pro-american I mean the connections are
obviously huge because so many of its
Sons and Daughters left and many of them
went to America and made something of
themselves so I think it's it's nice to
have some of these people return create
new links between Ireland and America
this is particularly important now 25
years since the Good Friday agreement
was signed
The Landmark peace deal between
Republicans and unionists in Northern
Ireland was negotiated with U.S help I
think for America it sort of brings a
reminder of the of the times in the
world when American hard power and soft
power can sort of make a difference for
good the president had the opportunity
during his visit to push for its
preservation amid political instability
in the region as a friend I hope it's
not too presumptuous for me to say that
I believe Democratic institutions
established through the Good Friday
agreement remain critical to the future
of Northern Ireland The Good Friday
agreement isn't is an unquestioned win
for peace and America was a big part of
that so I think Biden's going to rightly
sort of celebrate that your history is
our history
but even more important your future
is America's future
[Music]
foreign